in season four of Riverdale CW's team
drama paid tribute to hedvik and the
Angry Inch in the episode chapter 74
Wicked little town Casey cots Kevin
Keller decides it's time for Riverdale
High to host variety shows again when
principal honey warns Kevin not to
perform any numbers from Hedwig Kevin
and his friends fight back by performing
multiple numbers from the musical during
the hedvig original tear me down Kevin
and KJ appa's Archie lock lifts Cod
explained to TV Insider that there is a
part of the hedvik stage musical when
the titular hero goes into the audience
and kisses an audience member inspired
by this while filming his performance of
tear me down with cots Kevin Keller
playing Hedwig Kant kissed APA on the
cheek but then as Cod explained the next
take I went in to do the same thing and
APPA turned his face and we just kind of
laid a big one on each other and then
after that we were like this is exactly
what it should be this is like perfect
for this number